what about on the solo tip obviously uh  what are you working on right now  because like i said man you're on  everything right now and  i know people are wanting like a full a  full-length blast album  and right now i'm just working on being  the best live performer like i feel like  that's what  i've been missing or what i haven't been  giving to people like that that live  version of blast so the tour sold out  fast exactly so i'm trying to just  perfect the show and just  rehearsing a lot yeah rehearsing trying  to work out get right get in shape  all that type of [ __ ] vocal lessons is  that the hardest part about performing  is like  getting out of breath man i don't know  what it was about the pandemic but  i'd be tired nah for sure what